yeah it's just a warning side I'm not
trying to be misogynistic but I'm
telling you like having cats and rapping
is not where you're going to find your
higher purpose and it's not going to
give you the satisfaction of life that
you could find if you submitted to a man
is is that more impactful on the world
at 65 than having five kids so so
because once When You're Gone who cares
your career is gone what do you what do
you have to show for it in the world my
music do you hate women and you said oh
I don't hate women but I hate women that
fix so yeah I wouldn't even really
consider that a woman I don't I don't
really find you very feminine you're not
you're not you're not I'm not sad that's
okay I don't find you masculine so going
back to you guys's Point why because I'm
only 23 so I'm kind of torn between
whether I would want to continue working
after I have kids from your opinion like
why would you feel like women working is
something that they shouldn't do it's
not that you should or shouldn't it's
just ideally no if you're with the right
man then you wouldn't have to work if
you want to you can but I would rather
that you raise the kids yeah who's who's
gonna be watching the kids when you're
at work some babysitter and so then you
have a stranger influencing your kid
more than you are and you have to look
at it as a place of trust and love he
picked you he he trusts you and picked
you over every woman in the world put
his children in you and instilled that
trust in you to take care of them while
he's away making sure the family is
taken care of is there a more important
duty I just listen
I think that women in the workplace I
think women kill it in fact my
Construction Company
all of my managers outside the managers
that are in the field are women and
they're very good at they're very
organized I call them my Trojan horses
because they get more in a negotiation
than a man could because it's not a dick
measuring thing right but at the same
time a lot of those women are past the
years of being a mother and their kids
are grown and they're in their 50s and
their professional business women but I
suspect that any woman that gets a high
level guy who chooses her and chooses to
trust
her with one of the most important
things in this world his children
that should be an honor past any other
job that I can think of for a woman now
does that mean that a woman can't go out
there and make money and have an impact
on the world outside to be a mother no
it doesn't women can just buy in largely
on the macro what a beautiful job to
have
mm-hmm yeah it's just a warning side I'm
not trying to be misogynistic but I'm
telling you like having cats and rapping
is not where you're going to find your
higher purpose and it's not going to
give you the satisfaction of life that
you could find if you submitted to a man
and it's submitting doesn't have to be
suppressing it's not misogynistic to
submit to your husband that's a woman's
happiest state is submitting to a man
that she loves 100 woman he's 100 right
you know you know what I believe if if
more women would take that role there'd
be less women on antidepressants but
there are a lot of women here who are
willing to take that role so what is
your point there are a lot of women who
share this mentality you're not
different than them no I am I've made
that clear I'm not gonna lie you're not
like other women no I'm not I don't want
what other women or traditional women or
women that are that what every woman
wants I have a different dream I have a
different purpose
no did I say that and I'm asking what is
your dream no I'm sorry that I don't
dream to watch what is your dreams
I'm a rapper that's as far as it goes
and you know okay let's say you became
the world's biggest rapper yeah when you
took that to the to the extreme is is
that more impactful on the world at 65
than having five kids
so so because once when you're gone
who cares your career is gone what do
you what do you have to show for it in
the world my music
go straight well stream it love it you
know
um
so that's that's better than a child
no no one said that but I'm just saying
but you're not you're not saying
anything
what I'm saying is back to what this guy
said I could I just don't like them and
I keep saying it because I can see it
like the way so you skip the dream part
I'm misogynistic wow
no you're not you're not you're you are
misogynistic but you're not gonna admit
it that's the thing like you don't think
I hate women you don't think but yes I
do some of the women that you probably
met okay actually you know I figured it
out a lot I figured it out I don't hear
women at all you said that you're not
like other women
I don't like that I don't like women who
think that they're different who want to
be men who want to be rappers who want
to be I have no problem with women I
have a problem with women that don't
even can't Define misogyny but calling
me misogynistic I prefer rapping over
having children
right now I literally asked you what did
I just ask you I said what um
do you hate women and you said oh I
don't hate women but I hate women that
fix so yeah I wouldn't even really
consider that a woman I don't I don't
really find you very feminine you're not
you're not you're not and that's sad
that's okay I don't find you masculine
so the feeling is mutual my point but
you have the mentality on of these
social media men like the men on social
media who have so much to say internet
Warrior's let they've got so much to say
about what a woman should do how a woman
should dress how I should look you're
not feminine like oh like yeah there are
women that are not feminine women like
this is the real world yeah
and they die alone
they don't get paid women outlive men
anyways and with why would you want it's
not a competition I'm not saying it is
but statistically women outlive men so
what's your plan my point is that it's
not it's not misogyny you didn't have it
consciously like you have misogyny you
have misogynistic views yes it's not
anything you do you I you know for free
and that's coming from a woman okay
you're not very well but the majority of
the women's in the room said he wasn't
misogynist and the majority and the
women in this room come from religious
backgrounds etc etc so they have a
certain things why did it come from a
religious background my mom my mom's
catholic but she never pushed it upon us
when we was growing up I grew up pretty
much with no religion I I've been to
church maybe twice in my life so I
wouldn't say I grew up with a religious
okay I don't think he's misogynist and
I'm also grew up in a church but my
parents didn't talk to me about marriage
until my 20s because it was you know I
was too young so I've only just
discovered and liked these things and
preferred these things just recently so
let me explain let me explain what uh
your vibration and what you're saying
and why a lot of people watch the show
and the importance of these podcasts is
that there's a frustration that men have
dealing with Western women because
they're extremely masculine they're
combative they think that they're equal
they don't make a lot of sense they talk
out of their mouth they're always on
social media and then when you travel
outside of the West and you see women
who are actually feminine I just spent
three weeks in Japan and it is a breath
of fresh air to see women who are
naturally in that state who act like
women who don't prioritize rapping over
being mothers people who are happy that
there's a binary that there's men and
women there's none of this confusion
there's none of this back and forth
there's not this competition that's what
the frustration is is that this is not
natural the way that you're acting your
career path and your dreams your
unwillingness to Define misogyny your
world view is frustrating to deal with
it's not hatred it's I'm trying to
explain that and wide men and probably
why it's going to be difficult for you
to settle down with the husband because
you don't want to submit to a man and
that's how we're going to be happiest
that's why there's a rise in depression
that's why there's a rise in suicide and
antidepressants and all this this is the
root of the problem is feminism it's
it's not it has nothing to do with
hatred it has nothing to do with that
but me hating you I honestly don't care
about you I probably wouldn't talk to
you if this wasn't on a podcast I'm
trying to explain a feeling that a lot
of people are gravitating to and why red
pill is blowing up so much because it's
tapping into this feeling that a lot of
people realize now and they don't really
know why but this is what it is can I
say something quickly do you know why I
like African men more in terms of like
my taste because culturally the same way
that you're saying when you go outside
the West when you go outside the West
when I go outside the West I'm more
likely to find your average guy as an
African man who has done a lot more
money things the West the men in the
west actually they are a bit soft in the
sense of yeah you can go make your money
and have a career but being a man is
more than the money in your pocket so
actually the problem goes both ways
there's a lot of men that are not doing
what they're meant to do as naturally
masculine men no absolutely and I mean I
always say because I travel around quite
a lot you know I've been to Eastern
Europe and also into
um uh into South America as well when
you go outside of the West when you go
outside of the Anglo sphere you see the
difference you see and a lot of this
stuff talk about now is very culturally
defined it's very it's a it's a hot
House of this debate that's going on in
England and it's going on in America and
it's going on in Canada and Australia
outside of the these places very very
different it doesn't exist
yeah and my point is that it's not
really what you naturally want you've
been programmed by social media you've
been programmed I guarantee you listen
to Meg the stallion and cardi B you
follow a lot of celebrities on Instagram
and I guarantee you have a lot of
provocative pictures on Instagram this
is this is what happens when you follow
that path and when you think that being
a mother is comparable to being a cow
it's not what you naturally want you
have been brainwashed you wouldn't be
with a woman who makes more than you so
you'll brainwashed yourself babe you
would find it emasculating like you
don't like the fact that there's women
now who can earn the same amount as you
doing the same thing as you actually
earn more than you doing the same thing
as you name one relationship where
that's working and I've asked you the
same question and you couldn't so what's
your plan what is your relationship
where are the man's in charge and the
man makes more can I tell a factual
story my parents
um sorry cardi B one of the biggest
rappers actually came out on Twitter and
she said she wants to stop rapping and
just focus on raising her children
because that's what makes her happy so
do you still feel like you know being a
rapper is what's going to give you
genuine happiness if the biggest rapper
in the world is willing to give that up
she got cash
and they sell you a lie they go on a
song and say I don't cook I don't clean
and then they really want to or Beyonce
will make a song All the Single Ladies
and she's married so they're good and
stayed with a guy that she did and
they're instilling this brainwashing
because it sounds good because it makes
you feel empowered it gives you dopamine
in the moment but it's not really what
gives you long-term serotonin actual
happiness actual higher purpose it's a
drug it's like smoking a cigarette can
you cook can you hunt
yeah I can yeah can you fight of course
okay that's good yeah
fighting this is so you're good you're
you're still a hot man deep down even
though you started the career online
looking for trouble you're still a man
no I didn't start it there's a lot of
men there's a lot of men that can't do
that I'll ask them can you hunt them
like
um can you tell them to and this is the
reason that Justin wall is so successful
and why people like need this online is
because men can't live in this I don't
believe in I'm not gonna say you need to
improve or else you're going to fall
behind yeah women can believe in this
delusional they can just believe in
nothing they can say I'm gonna be a
rapper with cats when I'm 65 and then
people won't check you and if I do check
you I'm misogynistic when you uplift men
and you tell them the truth it's like yo
thank you for telling me that I need to
improve women don't want to hear it they
want to stay in this cycle of nothing
yeah I guess I mean because obviously
you're not sitting here with guys that
are not like you then you can't sit in
obviously say yes
I do I have my friends from back in the
day from back in New York a lot of them
are still in the same spot that they
were in college and I tell them man like
you gotta you got to step your game
that's good so I'll talk to them the
same way so you know it sounds
aggressive but that people need to hear
that I don't know because no one talks
them like that okay so that's nice
because you saying that and you being
able to own up to own up to that brings
more balance to your argument because
the problem is when we sit in these
conversations we're usually saying women
women well the difference is the men for
the men to get on this podcast here's
the difference you can just be a girl
and be on this podcast we don't really
care what you've done to be a man of
this podcast you've had to have done
something yeah they're not just gonna
you think they're gonna go to a club and
like recruit guys to be here yeah yeah
you wouldn't sit here these guys are
accomplished in their field that's why
we get to sit down with average women
and you know why you get to sit down
with average women knowing me included
because thank you because actually
there's a massive need and uh you know
urge for people to get onto women which
I do get but then there's also a moment
where you have to chill out because
you're not actually speaking to just
average women you don't actually know
it's from anywhere so when you have an
attitude of almost like wanting to make
us look patronize almost what we say
with such a challenge yeah that's why
you come across as misogynist well I
need to get through because this is a
common problem that a lot of guys face
she started off by saying she's
vibrating with misogyny and then you
know and not me and my what I was what
are filters and then people don't check
that like it's important to check that
out you can't just let that slide well
then what I feel to say
um
actually never mind exactly like you
need to you need to call it out when
people make no sense or else we're gonna
keep living in class can I challenge you
both can I challenge you both
um so
I feel like these new intimate men are
like very destructive to these young men
out there because you have of you have
an opinion you have a voice you're very
vocal about it and you stand strong in
your plane and like you know you've got
this Andrew take passport Bros thing is
that what you're getting at because
you're that's oh going back in different
countries women are feminine
sounding like some nonsense stuff that
other guys jump because the guy's never
gonna look at a woman to for influence
like let's be real and real well not
real men a lot of men will not look and
this is where
um in rap and other careers Fields where
women are at the top men will not they
look they don't look at you and think oh
yeah but this person can influence this
this person can influence me or this
person like it can't come from a woman
but whereas if Andrew Tate does it it's
like oh yeah let's jump on the bandwagon
because he's the guy I'm a guy like you
only want to relate to someone because
of yeah
that's happening though is because
people like Tate and you know the
gentleman sitting here are redressing
the balance because they're and the
reason that they've they've been so
popular they've blown up to such the
extent is because they're going against
what is the prevailing narrative for the
prevailing narrative is basically
telling guys you know be a nice guy
uh buyer flowers you know take on 15
dates you know this kind of thing and
and all of that kind of thing hasn't
worked but the first thing that he said
is that he's a nice guest so we found
what you mean he's a nice guy yeah so
what does that mean then so he's a nice
guy but he's like this and he's like
that like it's not making any sense like
I said these internet boys there's a lot
of men on the internet are being
brainwashed like they are because like
the women okay yeah the women aren't
being brainwashed but yeah we have maybe
a few sensible men who can go you know
you're not gonna go for everything
what do they say why do they say that's
not true what have they said Andrew
Andrew one thing he said not true
I don't disagree with what Andrew Tate
says
he's saying it like there's a way to say
it and I don't agree
[Music]
that's the perfect point because
brainwashing implies that you're lying
that you're feeding him a lie it's not
what I'm saying because you can't refute
any of it it's how I'm saying it and
this is the Western World We prioritize
the way you feel your vibrations of
misogyny over what is true and what's
false but people are not gonna listen to
you if you're not telling the truth what
you're saying is flying over a lot of
people's heads or you want no not mine
because I don't believe in what you're
saying anyway like you you said you know
a woman's nature like you don't you will
never know a woman's nature you don't
bleed once a month bro you're never
gonna do no but it's a woman's nature so
what are you talking about it's a
woman's nature female nature
I want to hear from you I just thought
you haven't talked much so yeah I know
um I don't think that's got anything to
do with it and another thing I want to
go back to the misogyny thing I feel
like people just throw around whatever
they feel whatever they want to say but
they don't want to hold accountability
for it like you don't you can just say
whatever you can say whatever but he
can't say the same thing because then he
will you know you will throw a [__] fit
can I challenge the both of you um I'm
sure most of you guys can agree that men
are becoming more feminine
can you kind of understand why that's
forced women to almost become more
masculinity
yeah can we just say one thing though
this is why because you've mentioned
Angie type people like that and
obviously as you said the gentleman here
the reason that those people have risen
to prominence is because
the the West is out of balance right
they are there redressing the balance
they're going against the prevailing
narrative and and the main thing that
they're preaching everybody is
self-improvement because men have to
like you said men have to step up we
don't get a choice to not step up we
can't just say oh well I'm just you know
I'm just living my truth and you know
it's all going to be fine we have to put
in the work otherwise we're just going
to get left on the sidelines women have
more Advantage than that for the most
part but to go back sorry to stop you
just to go back to my question like can
you both understand why women have now
become more masculine so for example
like a woman her husband has left the
family and now she's forced to become a
more masculine and work and just do more
masculine things so would you guys now
look down on her because she's been
forced to play a position that she had
no choice but to yeah but women leave
more marriages than men do
like 80 of divorces are initiated I
forgot yeah and women and women always
worked they just worked in the house
like they always worked they were they
were in the field in the plow like if
anything they worked more but the
previous generations but they still kept
the femininity what I'm trying to say is
that women have become more masculine
and I feel like do you guys somewhat
understand why or do you think we're
just waking up and deciding let's just
be feminine because as much as I feel
like feminism is a dark thing there's a
slight part of me that can understand
why women have been forced to play this
masculine role and do you guys even
acknowledge it or do what I still think
is a mindset so this is why it's not
misogyny is I completely understand why
I think a lot of trans people for
example are men turning into women
because it's getting harder to perform
as a man and so they'd rather go and
become women in that sense if the
brainwashing is equal there's there's an
equal amount of brainwashing on the on
the masculine side to become more
feminine and to paint your nails and to
to act like that and you see it being
pushed by YouTube and these platforms
they encourage it they clap it they're
very yes Queen they say yes Queen to men
you see who the men that are getting
propped up in the most famous pop stars
and music celebrity they're they're all
about
you see the agenda and that's the
problem with the world the problem with
the world is actually weak men I in no
way shape or form would ever allow it to
come out of my mouth that This Woman's
fault it is weak men that is letting
these things happen
if we if men got together and said this
this promiscuity is [__] if men got
together and said hey we need to step up
and be stronger and be better that is
the only thing that I allow a woman to
actually let go and let him take that
masculine role the women hold on and
it's hard for women because they're like
[__] can this [__] do it can he take
care of me or is he going to come home
and cry to me about his job no seriously
like because you come home we were
talking we had a heated conversation
yesterday about why men should not go
cry to their woman I am a big believer
that a man should never cry or show
emotion from a woman and the reason is
because you're if you were to translate
the words he's screaming I can't take
care of the situation you can't trust me
and so the woman's like man I better get
masculine real quick it's like what
you're talking about with a man dies
women are scared that a man cannot that
because men are weak men are [__]
weak and if men were stronger women
could trust them more and let go and
whether you like it or not fall into
that feminine frame because I think
that's what they're naturally
for pins to do so would you say weak men
is the roots of absolutely the weak men
are the biggest problem in the world
we've men are in charge now it used to
be that the the masculine leader the
fighter or somebody like that the the
warrior would lead charged but ever
since technology social media you could
be able to poke girls I say this all the
time Mark Zuckerberg and created
Facebook he was a nerd and he started
like he based Facebook off of hot or not
and so now this nerd was able to go and
uh own the sexual Marketplace he was
able to judge all these women who would
have he would have never had access to
before and that was a shift in 2007 now
the nerd is in charge rather than the
warrior so now that they've acknowledged
that men can be weak would you still say
they're misogynistic
not can be are men are weak and that's
why Andrew is so popular yeah but my
point is that the fact that the both of
you can actually sit here and
acknowledge that man men being weak is
the cause of you know just this
destruction of relationships could you
now see that they are not misogynistic
if they can see both sides of the
you know panel plane whatever the scene
is
no comment
um guys I'm gonna take a second to read
Super Chat um sneako I know you have to
get going are you reason what yeah I got
some time okay okay I don't wanna okay
um so guys I'm gonna read all super
chats that are over 20 so if you want me
to read your super chat um make sure
it's over 20 because we're not reading
the ones below it um okay quickly though
you can give a comment it's okay we
don't need to keep on arguing I don't
understand you don't want to submit and
you think it's suppressing but we can be
on the same page if you can submit to me
then we can be on the same page submit
to what as in my femininity submit to
your femininity come home to her give
her kisses sometimes
do what you think a woman needs to do
and have the baby so do you want a
masculine man or a feminine man what
obviously I'm masculine like obviously
men men don't know each other so if you
want a masculine man if you want a
masculine man then I can't submit to you
oh
do you want a relationship or not with
somebody not me
definitely because what you're saying
makes no sense like well what am I
saying you're saying that you want me to
submit to you and you want me to cook
and clean for you but also you want to
master maybe let your guard down a
little bit become more vulnerable that's
what men do you know men do clean men do
submissive things do you want a husband
that's going to cook and clean for you
cooking is not submissive cooking is
just it's a simple question yeah but
he's saying so are you saying that
cooking and cleaning is as a man is
submissive yes that's crazy do you want
a husband that cooks and cleans for you
why not okay have you ever been in love
of course okay so when you were with
your girlfriend were you always this
like I'm a man or you're not able to
just like chill out a little bit and
cuddle with her and sometimes she's the
one giving you massage and you're giving
her kisses and being cute to her I've
tried it doesn't work does work that's
actually quite nice a lot of men the men
that are in a relationship can do that
not anymore okay well there you go yes
no but I do know a lot of men and I know
this because that's the reason why I
always say men talk so much but they
don't know each other as deep as they
think they do because men change
completely in the private company of a
woman as well so that's why power
couples make all the big moves in this
world
I say there are power couples in the
world but I think most couples that are
successful aren't really a power couple
it's just a very very strong man and a
very very supportive onboard woman now
there is Jay-Z and Beyonce but I do
think they're outliers
don't know what's going on in their
relationship they don't seem that happy
to me I'm not gonna lie there's been
public well they're fighting over who
has the dick
honestly in a lot of ways and I don't
think that's healthy at all in no way do
I think a man and a woman in a
relationship should compete for who the
man is going to be and I think that's
probably the overarching problem with
feminism is that you have a man and a
woman in this power struggle over
something that has traditionally been
successful being the man's role and
that's not to belittle a woman is to put
her in her grace and her beauty and
everything that's wonderful about women
it's it's it's a lame thing and and
nobody's you know it's not about being
right or wrong it's like what are we
wired to do I agree with you earlier I
would never drop my children off to a
daycare with men running it women are
better at it they're nurturing they have
these skill sets it's about that it's
not about you know which one of us are
going to take the lead because I I
cannot find a relationship and I would
challenge you to find a relationship
that's really going to work with a
woman's leader in the alpha how can how
can she respect him and if she doesn't
respect him how can she love him I mean
there's the Queen Margaret fat Margaret
Thatcher that's a good example of her
being the Prime Minister and I would
call it an outlier I call it an outlier
if you took if you took a hundred
relationships you still probably
wouldn't have the queen or Margaret
Thatcher in it and I can tell you the
more dominant she gets and pearl will
probably admit this the bigger your
channel gets the harder it will be to
find a man on your level because you
make a lot of money facts are you ready
I'm doing okay
but you're very based and you do
understand the more influence you get
the taller you are the more money yeah
the harder it is yeah but you can still
find absolutely can I want to correct
something it's not intimidating to guys
no guy is intimidated by what I do uh
it's not intimidating it in a sense it
just doesn't typically work in
relationships and the woman makes more
than the man yeah so they're a bit more
shook to even go no they're not they're
not because they know that if they go
try and try them with pearl because
she's a g and I'm not I'm gonna get hurt
because I may fall in love with a girl
that is not gonna look up to me so I
better not go down a bit shook still I
have a question you know that are taller
than you that make more money than you
how many
um
not not many
um but yeah I know a couple but not many
yeah
I have a question oh is your like
podcasts more important to you than like
settling down and having children
now
no it's not okay then that's nice so
you're gonna abdicate of the jpt thing
so once say you was to find someone not
to like interview but if say you was to
find someone and they would want you to
like give up this whole podcast thing
and you are in love with them to have a
family would you do it yeah oh that's so
refreshing to hear yeah it's all the
equipment though I need to get my money
back on it
he tell you to put in storage you know
that's one of those things but that's
kind of what makes her a hero in a lot
of ways because she's sitting here doing
this thing that's going to counteract
really finding that dude and and she's
out here telling so many women Hey
listen you're probably going to be more
happy like this at the expense of
honestly herself in a lot of ways this
is a very expensive Penthouse right it's
a very big Channel she has it's like
people talk about boss [__] like
she's employing a lot of people you know
like you want to talk about God's work
like shout out to Pearl for that you
know I'll argue with you on a subject if
we have to but let's call it spade a
spade what she's doing is pretty
selfless in that regard
yeah I guess so she'd make plenty of
money as well from that it makes it hard
it's gonna make it harder for her
because even she knows she could get a
man right but the likelihood of him
being like what are you 5 11. six six
yeah six foot tall yeah six foot tall so
that that that's down to one percent of
the male population right before the
money right before the money and and the
clout
like think about you're talking about
point zero zeros or put that in the
delusion calculator and you guys still
aren't listening to what I mean Katie
Perry's her net worth is higher than her
husband she did all right so well I mean
what other option do I have I would die
alone
um
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
guys make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel okay
um God of Legends and why sneako has on
why does snico have on feminine pants um
that is like skinny jeans women wore in
the 90s he is wearing hey man he is
wearing um pure
um nut hugger pants
um Gora Legends um true that's why
sneako got his uh skinny jeans from the
female Department Lucifer I'm a question
for the guys do you Jay Waller Troy and
sneako have girlfriends who are
providing value to you as you speak and
if so what is the value are your woman
actually helping you build your Empire
how or so you guys preach a lot that's
actually a good question um that we can
come back to
um Nestle hustle um here is 20 for the
rapper chick to stop talking
um Jasmine what wish the women would
respond with an educational response
instead of an emotional one they're so
defensive and make it about themselves
instead of answering the question with
just logic and justification
um
Lawrence Bullock the goal of feminism is
to erase the difference between men and
women not equality Lawrence so any
criticisms of women is misogyny direct
from the feminism handbook
silly sausage hungry managed to find a
way to help monetize motherhood by
lowering income tax 25 for every child
that they have forever um four kids no
tax and guess what the feminists thought
about that you guessed right they hated
it
zero Fallout the myth of the
stay-at-home wife needs to be needs to
die throughout history the majority of
women have always worked in some way be
it in farms field the home or at the
market only in recent times has the
average been able to has the average
been able to have one
um Manny F during World War one and two
women had to go to factories and work in
order to support the men there in war
and still took care and still took care
of the children then lived a much harder
life how are women today suppressed and
what would the panel do and would the
panel of women do the same sacrifice Ash
I'm showing my support from showing my
support your Chi-Town brother keep
Aiming High
and Let me refresh it really quick
um okay so what was the question that
they asked you guys I want to find it
again okay
do you guys have girlfriends providing
value to you as you speak and if so what
is the value are your women actually
helping you build your Empire how so
yeah I have a couple girlfriends right
now I know it's Haram but one of them
runs my Discord server and she's she's
on top of things when I was getting a
lot in a lot of drama she was there and
she was able to take care of it and make
sure that it was running properly I have
one that wants to become my assistant
and I'm training her to run my
accounting and do the taxes and do the
paperwork when I get tickets I'm going
to try to get her to quit her job and be
my assistant the other one uh working on
traveling with her and she recently got
a big payout so I'm gonna go travel with
her and she's there she helps me find
other girls as well so and the other one
the other one needs work but all of them
add something to my life and all of them
help
then play their role properly if they
were completely useless I think that
it's not worth my time or theirs
what about you there's no woman in my
life it's not an asset to me
you think like a pimp and love and
profile like a hero straight up like
there's no woman it's not an asset
what about you what was the question
again sir um do you have girlfriends
providing you value as you speak and if
so what is the value
I mean yeah absolutely they all provide
value because otherwise why would you
spend time with them right I mean but
the way that they provide value is is
um not material but it's sort of like in
terms of sustenance in terms of in terms
of feminine energy it's in terms of you
know having somebody there who kind of
gets you
um there's many many ways in which they
provide value 100
so I have a question for the women um do
you want to be married and have kids yes
um if so what age do you want to be
buried and how many kids I would love to
be married with kids tomorrow but
um that's not happening because I still
need to work on myself
um I would ideally like to do that like
25 25 how many kids do you want I want
four four kids okay what about you um I
would like to be married I would like to
have children
um maybe my late 20s I haven't really
thought too much into it but how do you
know I'm 22. I've never been in a
relationship so I haven't really got an
exact age where
I would say I want to get married I
don't feel like I need to meet someone
first to put a time frame on it why late
20s late 20s yeah one or sooner
[Music]
um
I just feel like I want to travel and
live my life to the fullest and then
when I'm ready to be selfless then I'm
ready to settle down and have children
and start a family wouldn't you prefer
to travel with your husband I would love
to travel with someone I travel a lot on
my own so it would be nice to travel
with someone
what does live your life mean I hear
that a lot from from good girls like you
and then live your life in if we're
going to be honest what does live your
life really mean you're traveling living
your life what come on to travel and to
live my life honestly I think travel is
the best education that you can get I
think it's better than any school that
you can go through I think you learn
about the real world when you travel you
learn about different cultures you meet
so many different people and that's why
I love to travel
do you think you're gonna have an easier
time finding your husband now when
you're 22 you haven't had a relationship
or when you're in your late 20s and
you've already definitely
um definitely earlier on but to get
married because obviously you're not
going to meet someone straight away and
get married to them in an instant you're
going to have a relationship with them
first I assume anyway
um so yeah I could meet someone when I'm
like 25 and then I could get married
when I'm 28 but that's still
yeah
can I chime in in the conversation I
it's clear that the point that you're
trying to make is that you're the
younger you are the better chances you
have of finding someone I think you
should start looking now instead of put
it off but I think I think I think it'll
be okay I'm not paying your office I
think when it happens it happens kind of
thing I'm not gonna
um go out of my way and and search for
it and make it my sole purpose but I
think when the time is right
um the world will give me someone that's
meant for me
can I ask you a question so do you think
um age is an indicator for you as to
picking a partner like is it is it like
if she's older then you don't want her
if she's younger it's pretty like
preferably your your
type of woman has to be between a
certain age Etc or have you like
is well what's your name by the way me
yeah Dania Danielle is like a perfect
example of a girl that I would date that
I would like to go out with 22 hasn't
had a relationship uh very pretty I
would rather date her now than when she
was 32 and travel the world completely
agree
you know why
because a man that's traveled the world
like we've all done here
we know that the girl that has Instagram
photos and multiple multiple countries
was not only living her life but
statistically I slept with a lot more
men
yeah that's what the journey means and
we call it the [__] Carousel and I don't
mean to be crude but
a woman that has been more promiscuous
and traveled more and done all these
different things then what do you have
to give her that's going to make her
life magic anyway so when we're talking
about being the hero and wanting like no
man wants a woman that he can't save
from a castle on a dragon that doesn't
mean the woman needs to be saved or
she's broken that's the beautiful thing
about love so if she's done all the
experience for example if you get in a
Lamborghini and you know how to use the
handle on the door it tells me something
you understand what I'm saying now if
you can't get in you're like how does it
like when a girl gets in my G-Wagon if
she can't like I'm like huge turn on nah
I want to show you the world Danielle I
want someone else to show you
but does what I'm saying makes sense
like a man wants a woman that has
preserved herself in many many ways like
you have no relationships so if if a
woman has done
um any sort of sex work it's not oh
that's completely out obviously yeah
that's very obvious yeah I would never
wife up a girl that her job was to have
sex with men no that's absolutely
foolish but hoes get wife the quickest
you know because they're stamps they're
the easiest ones and then it fails
because they don't the the hoe or the
the sex worker doesn't want to have sex
for money any longer so she finds some
fool to pay for her life and then she
texts me and I'll sleep with her are you
on only fans no not me do you understand
what I'm saying like that's like no
quality man no man that's going to be
worth this salt is going to pick up a
sex worker no
why would he have to because if he's
high level he can get a girl like her
and I don't even mean that to be
disrespectful like I'm not trying to
disrespect sex workers I'm telling you
right now I would never marry one well
first of all marriage is a different
subject but I would never make her you
know pretty serious part of my life at
all ever but then don't you pay for it
who pays for it no I'm just saying
because there's men I have this um
ideology no I said every woman is an
asset okay a man's job is to build a
woman to the woman that it takes to take
her where he's going interesting build
her a man should build a woman and and
that means by investing into her like
hey baby I just said this yesterday it's
like Hey listen we're gonna go to this
event I'm gonna get you this dress
do it like this little less titties the
for the forks start here and go in you
wanna you wanna build her up and make
her be able to come up because you're
trying to get up the social classes
right if you really love her you'll
develop her and build her to take her
with you that's what you do for a woman
that's how you build a woman but a woman
that's been giving her body away to all
the other guys at the table because the
rich guys that pay for sex they'd be
like I had that girl last year in
morbayo bye yeah no [__] way no
[__] way
do you want to be married
skip me please
um I marriage in the traditional sense
is not really something that bothers me
I'd rather have you want to do the two
houses thing don't you I'd rather have a
partnership and I'd rather have a man
present in my life but it doesn't have
to be like overarching and overwhelming
with the way that people are making it
seem nowadays like I fully agree with
what you're saying I think that for me
to be able to actually take a man very
seriously it has to be a man that can
actually bring something new to my life
you know with somebody that I can look
up to and I can be like okay you're
teaching me something new okay
I need you to answer the question do you
want to be married yes or no I want to
have a partnership marriages okay okay
so you don't care about being married on
paper now you want a relationship yeah
okay okay do you want kids yes or no
yeah definitely okay how many kids
in the world of today I think it's safe
to have two two kids okay and you're 30.
yes um so when do you want to be in a
relationship and when do you want to
have the kids uh since it's just been
about like a year since I've rebuilt my
life
um
I'd say maybe like
I'll probably pick my husband about six
months okay so in the next six months
you're gonna find a house do you have
some prospects yeah of course okay you
see you got you got a list I've got I've
well anyone anyone in the chat and he's
ready to marry you within six months
yeah okay and so then you're gonna or
not sorry not getting married but being
that in a relationship it's very listen
and then what do you when do you want
your first kid back
um I mean I don't really go into people
to meet people superficially I tend to
go quiet
so wait wait I'm just giving you 31 32
33 34 35 maybe like it depends on how
the relationships 32 33 it's not about
age about how many minutes
no no essentially I'm not going to say I
want to have a kid by 31. I mean you're
running out of eggs saying a lot no well
I do I just being 30 doesn't mean you
don't have eggs
geriatric pregnancy starts at 35. that's
fine I've got five years alone okay okay
so but what age had to look for what age
what age do you want to have your first
kid I would like to have my first kid uh
when me and my husband have established
that we are ready you just said you
don't want to be married well okay that
talking out of both sides of the mouth
once again okay
once me and my son my hubby yeah which
not on paper but in life once medium
established that we can't get on then we
are ready for the thing that's it I'm
not gonna say I want these kids when
he's not ready okay so you're gonna have
the kids when he's ready when we're both
ready okay
yeah I wanna all right when when do you
want to be married how many kids do you
want and what age do you want to have
kids um I want to be married by 25 and I
want to have two kids by 30 and then my
third kid before I'm 35. yeah how old
are you now 19. oh okay yeah
19 that's good yeah that's a really good
ones that to have at 19. that's really
good thanks
um
so I'm 21.
um I am
want to be married by 25 that's my aim
and then children I want as soon as
possible once I'm married yeah how many
I like kids so four maybe four kids four
kids yeah four kids
but then again I don't know I think
I've got a major problem because
I'm finding it very difficult to find
the right person and I don't know if I'm
the problem or if it's the men or what
are you looking for
um someone definitely more dominant than
me
um I feel like as if I've gone too far
down the career route and I've obviously
I'm only 21. I've done it a lot okay
what have you done
um so I've got my dream job I'm an
executive assistant uh so that was like
what I wanted to do I work for a really
big family I've got my dream car
um and then for me to go out there and
try to find a man who's able to beat
that because obviously that's what women
want they want someone bigger than them
someone stronger someone more masculine
dominant but then I can't find that I
don't know why I do know why because
we're surrounded by very weak men
unfortunately
so mighty boys yeah
but yeah I'm not going to speak too much
do you have like an income requirement
yeah how much does he have to make
um I would say about
at least 25 more than me and men images
which is roughly it will have to be in
like the 40 45 48 000 kind of Mark okay
so that's like in US Dollars that's like
55.60 yeah something like that you can
find that guy yeah that's not crazy can
I say something just quickly too no no
I'm gonna I'm gonna so um I'm curious to
the guys what are the best places for
women to find husbands
that's a good question
nowadays A lot of it happens online a
lot of people Instagram DM but I think
like you should go put yourself in
situations where I think the farmer's
market go grocery shopping I think the
church you should go find a guy there
a picnic like a little Park you know
just go to cute places I met I met a lot
of great couples recently in Japan they
met at the beach you know I don't I
think that if you are in your feminine
nature and you are doing things that
coincide with that you'll you can find
that guy I hear a lot of females say um
there's a whole lot of accounts on Tick
Tock that base their content off of how
to find a successful rich man or how to
do this or how to do that
um and they usually say they usually
Target Mayfair Knightsbridge go to this
bar go to this club I wouldn't I
wouldn't seek that out I I don't
immediately you put yourself in the
scenario that guys at that level are not
looking for you don't want a girl who's
clubbing I think the I think what sneako
said is is important being in your
feminine energy where wherever you go
you're gonna more likely attract a
better quality of man because the
problem with Mayfair and and you know
Kensington and nicebridge in these
places is you're going to meet a lot of
guys who just want to have one-night
stands but equally you're going to meet
them online as well so
um it's it's really about the energy
that you put out in terms of what you
attract but I think as well going to
some more like chilled out places going
to Borough market like he said go to
Whole Foods you know those kind of
places more likely to meet somebody
who's a bit more authentic than maybe
the most beneficial glamorous yeah yeah
Jim's good although as long as you don't
start filming him and putting it on
please don't do that
what do you think
it's hard because it depends on what you
mean how you define the man right Whole
Foods I don't grocery shop anymore so I
don't think you're gonna find a one
percenter in there but at the same time
you know
you have to find them somewhere so I
think sneako's dead on with the online
thing and then it comes down to
filtering and asking the right questions
but being respectful inside those
questions you know say and just be hat
in hand honest like look man I'm looking
for this kind of guy you know and 50 60
Grand he also nailed that that's not
going to be a problem for you in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if you got a bunch
of messages after this show because
that's so very obtainable now right so
you need to aim higher yeah and I think
you could I think I think you can get a
higher okay yeah you could but um you
know also you have to understand that
guys that are pretty well to do have
pretty well to do Hobbies bro if I was a
girl I'd be playing golf like a
[__] you know what I'm saying
even if you suck yeah even if you're
trash even if you're trash you know so
it's like those types of things you know
where where do where do guys like that
meet up where are they and can it not be
in a bar scene because you don't want to
meet somebody you're going to be with
forever in a bar because the first
question you're going to get asked is
you have to carry that around in your
relationship oh we met in the club right
so I I would try not to meet a person in
the club honestly So when you say the
best place to meet someone is online how
do you portray yourself in the best way
possible online what is your ideal
ideally if you want to be wife material
I would make it be known that you had
curves without showing skin okay there's
a classy way to be sexy right you know
the woman that's like very clearly built
well but is not showing it but she's
still showing it just there's clothes
right yeah with a bit of mystery to it
right yeah and it'll drive men wild
because now if you go online and you
look at a girl's account and first of
all she's got the cleavage everywhere
but if you just scroll down a little bit
you can see exactly what her nipples
look like I don't want a woman like that
I don't want that you know why because a
man gets a lot of value from other men
out of how classy and how beautiful this
woman is and if she's out there
promoting it to the world number one
that's marketing so I would never accept
that as a man personally and then number
two everybody in that group is going to
look down upon that man because the
woman is out out their marketing and
they've all seen everything he's got so
the sacredness and and which is one of
the most beautiful things I believe that
a woman has is now given away so it's I
think it's very important to compete
because you are competing against bbos
and boob jobs and all those things but
even if you get a boob job there's a way
to show that you have big boobs and a
busty figure and you're in good shape
without actually showing it if that
makes sense what do you what do you
think about women that get plastic
surgery to attract men you think that's
a good idea I think you're smart I would
do it if I was if I was a woman I would
have fake boobs for sure if I didn't
have you know you understand what I'm
saying yeah let's not cap about that and
I'd also be in the squat rack and I'll
also be doing all the things that it
took to attract men the beauty is very
mathematical in a lot of ways the
attractive things about a woman like as
far as bust and shape and all those
things those things are very very very
real and although it sounds shallow is
the basis of the relationship is
attraction
so if you can be attracted to somebody
and then be and then another thing I
would be
at least well read understand politics
have a strong opinion because you're
going to want those kind of things
because I do there is nothing more
attractive for me than a woman that is
based
if a woman is based like we'll have a
strong opinion about the right things
yeah if you're a communist I don't want
to yeah like I mean I mean obviously a
feminist right and here's a news flash
for you most most successful men are
based in pretty much conservative if
you're talking politics right that's by
and largely and then if you get a lefty
that's successful he's probably going to
be kind of Simply you're probably going
to sacrifice some masculinity there you
know so for me the right Hobbies I like
the I like the whole foods thing but
online and then make sure you're the
kind of class that a man says okay I can
take her and like turn her and build her
and keep developing her because she's
already on the right path she's already
the right cloth men often pick the wrong
cloth as do women
but having to be in the right Claw from
the jump you're giving that man a canvas
to turn you into a queen
so that's what I would do can I ask the
question like I understand what
femininity looks like from a woman's
perspective but from a man's eyes like
what does femininity look like to you
guys because I might have a we might
have different opinions I don't think we
do oh really okay so what do you what do
you think the woman's perspective on I
think femininity is someone who's calm
someone who's able to submit someone
who's able to compromise thousand
someone who takes care of herself and
you got you guys just have the same
thing I think you want to be looking at
watchwords like classy demure modesty
you know and when you're constructing
say like an online profile it's those
kinds of things you want to be going for
like like Justin's just said I mean you
can look sexy but nice dress you know
not not going to sort of the Instagram
hoe kind of Route you know less is more
you know in it with a lot of these
things yeah because you're selling it
cheaper yeah yeah
oh that's true do any of you guys have
any other dating questions for the guys
if you'd want to know from like a man's
point of view
uh what do you think is the main problem
with men nowadays and the women that
they choose like why are they making
certain mistakes I think that ethics
happened a long time before you need
them so men
choose not to be in abundance in every
area of their life they're not taking
care of their Fitness they're not taking
care of their business they're not
taking care of their career their style
they're not well read They're not doing
all the things that they're supposed to
be able to do to tell a woman that comes
into their life Hey listen I can't put
up with this kind of behavior you can't
have your titties all over the internet
I can't accept that you have to be an
abundance to tell a woman no the woman
then this is not to disrespect women but
a woman needs to know that you can
replace her you need to be that kind of
man to earn that kind of respect from a
woman and when you can get in a position
with a woman where she knows you can
replace her with somebody else that
wants to be classy who wants to take
that role who wants to be submissive
inside a frame that you've earned then
you're in the right place and Men by and
largely are not doing that now they're
playing the video games and doing the
weed or whatever they're not supposed to
be doing and for that reason they make
sacrifices when it comes down to
relationship negotiations
that they shouldn't make and they don't
even want to make but that's the only
girl they got yeah and so if they would
have been working on themselves the last
few years they when it comes to the
point of something coming to a head they
can't look a woman in the eyes with
conviction and say this isn't going to
work I'm going to run I'm gonna be the
leader in this relationship they have to
cater but that wouldn't and what happens
with that is she sees him buckled
because he's not in abundance and then
she loses respect for him and if she
doesn't leave him she cheats what about
the mistake that a lot of athletes make
because they also seem to end up
sometimes with like absolutely so
there's buckets in life so the money
bucket can fill up you can be the
richest guy in the world and be a
[__] dork you could also be
completely jacked ripped you know Alpha
half game all those other things be
broke so a man can't just stop at one
thing so if you were look at like a
schedule of values of things in life you
have to be connected you have to have
influence you have to have money you
have to be fit you have to be worldly
well spoken and be able to be articulate
in a conversation and communicate
because a woman is really going to need
communication because it's going to get
emotional you know so you better have to
be Stern and direct but at the same time
a good communicator without arguing a
man has to have emotional intelligence I
will never raise my voice out of one
like a woman I'm seeing I'll never raise
my voice because it tells her that I'll
go down to a child level she has to
respect me there has to be that
dissonance because if she doesn't
respect me she's like man I need to find
a guy I respect I don't look up to this
guy this guy can't handle it yeah this
guy is childish he'll come down here
with me yeah that's not the way to do it
so
for me a man has to handle all these
different areas of his life and some of
these buckets fill and that's what
you'll see sometimes you'll see a guy
get ran over the coals because he's an
athlete so he had let's say maybe
Fitness and money but he didn't have all
those other things like frame and things
like that to make him a leader and the
next thing you know he's getting he's
getting divorced like that soccer player
yeah yeah that just got wrecked right
yeah no he didn't get wrecked he
actually won in that divorce something
did he yeah because she makes more money
than him secondly right well but let's
take any athlete that gets wrecked it
happens they get wrecked because they
they look at that one bucket
particularly a money bucket a lot of
times you see a lot of fat Rich guys
they get comfortable they think they're
the big boss but there's dudes out there
competing in every category yeah and you
have to and you have to have the frame
right I have a very burning question
that's been asked okay one second sneako
has to go so um thank you yeah thanks
for coming I wanted sneaker to answer
this question real quick real quick okay
I have a very abundant question that's
been answered a million times but I
really need to like um I still don't
understand why do men cheat like what
are the top five reasons
it's just now it's just on our DNA it's
never gonna stop I don't even think it's
worth asking that question just accept
it if you want that level of guy you
gotta accept it so there's no reason
there's just a natural thing that they
just cheat it's natural for us to do
that yeah could you expand on that
well the first thing I would say is that
a man will you call it cheating I think
a real man is going to tell you how he's
going to be from the jump there's
honesty it's the deceit that's the
problem every woman knows that if a man
could he would you know so I think the
deceit and not only deceit is that a lot
of times what happened is you the man
himself is not even showing up how he's
supposed to he's supposed to make this
commitment to provide and protect and
make your life this wonderful place and
he doesn't and on top of that he's a
liar and he's a coward because he was
scared of you to tell you you understand
what I'm saying like that is the most
deceitful thing on the planet because a
lot of times when the man is [__] the
woman expects sexual exclusivity but
they don't really expect it from like we
talked about yesterday they're not
really expecting from Drake now are they
you know what I'm saying so it's when a
guy doesn't show up he lies and he's a
coward where a woman's like okay I'm
leaving for sure leaving but if a man
were to sit down tell the truth be bold
and and a woman is based enough to say
you know what any man on the planet if
he could be rich Paul powerful
handsome whatever it is
he would absolutely have all the women
that he wanted I think the thing that
women mistake when it comes to the
subject of infidelity are sleeping with
women is that they feel like he must
love her or that they're on the same
level as the other woman because a lot
of times a woman is less attractive
that's not true it's just it's just
different and and men and women women
often tend to have sex when they have
true feelings for a man men are just not
that way
you know so it's it's the difference
between the Sexes but I think what's I
think women already know that it's the
deceit and the cowardness and the lack
of performance from the man that makes a
woman leave for that because if you got
a real good man that's a real good
father a real good husband a real
provider a real partner a real Rider
like somebody that'll sit down with you
when you're crying about it and like
really be there for you and hold it not
cry with you because we ain't crying
around here but but be there for you
truly and you know that they got you in
every way and you trust them and look up
to them and they're building you and
making you better dude you're not
leaving that guy no way
even if it hurts it even if you're gonna
say no right now
I've experienced it enough to know that
I'm right do high value men cheat every
one of them
no that's not true that's actually not
true 99
thank you for giving that one percent I
appreciate it I don't want a cat but I
think 99 though yeah oh wait can we get
95 plus Pearl's Dad
thank you thank you
and that's the thing though because it
used to trigger you a year ago right
when we'd have this conversation we've
done whole shows about this yeah and now
it doesn't I think that you see it
through a whole other lens the whole
show last night was about it in the
beginning of the show the girls were
pissed by the end they were like I'd
stay
you know and and it's it's just this
ugly truth about the word I don't like
it I'll say I told every girl last night
I would pay a million dollars to cut
that feeling off it is in us I saw
something a podcast the other day where
a man said if a man cheats women
shouldn't take it personal or should
they should just suck it up do you agree
because I don't think well so I don't
like that idea of just sucking it up if
you if you if she's like truly truly
hurt by it I think you need to sit in it
with her and be there for her like I
look a real man can slit a throat and
hold a baby in the same day that's my
definition of a man so you have to be
able to do both you know you need to be
hard hard and loving and there's no
problem being vulnerable with a woman or
like hey being there for her there's no
problem at all because if you're really
strong if anybody takes event tries to
take advantage of your vulnerability you
[__] crush them so you don't there's
not one woman on this Earth not one
woman fully commit to
no no no no no no no yes there are there
are women that I can fully commit to as
in you sexually no there's no no and
there's no man that would want to
if you lined up every man on the planet
and you said Hey listen I got this red
button I've said this on podcast before
nobody's looking nobody's gonna judge
you truly nobody's here every man in the
world they said you can be a great
husband a wonderful father you can go
home tuck your kids at night possibly
sleep with other women and then go home
and hold your wife and tuck in your
babies and provide and be a good husband
and father every man on the planet would
look left they'd look right and they'd
hit that button do you think cheating is
a good thing
no but it is just naturally part of the
male psyche it's it's what I think the
point the point is it's it's it's he can
absolutely love the woman you know she
can be his absolute Queen she is like
the the top
um but he's always gonna have that that
propensity to what variety that's what
it comes down to and like Justin said
that the other the other woman doesn't
even need to be that good she doesn't
even need to be as attractive she could
be ugly yeah I think these girls really
miss that and that whole time
the one he actually loves has the
ability probably to break his heart yeah
and and girls often ask well what's the
difference because I always thought that
if a man cheats he truly doesn't love
him oh no that's not true at all that's
not true at all that's not true at all
you know look I'm telling you right now
honey hungry and horny to a man's the
same thing you have filet mignon at home
but sometimes you just eat a corn dog
because it's different so would you say
a hole is a hole
do you if it's female like well I got
certain standards right so you know no a
hole is not a hole but at the same time
you would be surprised at how far down
the totem pole a man would go for
variety and they don't love what they
don't love these women they don't even
want them in their bed what if a dude
got another girl pregnant do you think
that the girl should leave
no
no because because it's really about him
showing up the way he's supposed to show
up women know men are this way all women
in their gut truly know men are this way
and a lot of times it's acceptable man
there's so many rap songs out there
talking about infidelity and [__]
hoes and [__] and the girls are in
the club just dancing what do you what
do you think are valid reasons for
women-ending relationships
a man not holding the correct frame not
being the man of the house being weak
being in a position where he's not being
the leader not taking responsibility not
stepping up not being a man specific
like example
um just like in a day-to-day
relationship of how that would play out
day-to-day relationship
I'll give you a great example men get
married every weekend in America
they stand in front of the church God
and both families and commit to the
woman
they tell her they're gonna basically
saying they're gonna give her the best
life they've made an agreement for that
man to work his ass off he comes home
he's complaining about his job but
instead of getting out there and
hustling and creating a better life for
them and to be a better father and a
better husband he pops open a beer
smokes a j and turns on the Xbox
and he's just
emotionally vomited all over his wife
which puts her in a position of feeling
fearful like this guy he's coming home
complaining about his job not doing a
[__] thing about it and then dumping
it on me now I have to work so we can
make the mortgage now our kids not might
have to go to a lesser School than they
would have our whole situation is [__]
because this guy didn't make a
commitment and he's fine with that
because he's going to trade off sex
right but here's a news flash his ass
will cheat on you too and when you find
out you're gonna leave him but the guy
that's taking care of business every way
making you feel safe giving you a life
that you'd have never had otherwise has
committed to you
and your happiness and even is there
when you're emotionally upset or feeling
pain that's the kind of man you want
a man again my definition is a man is
somebody that can slit a throat and hold
a baby in the same day and that really
sums it up because he's got to be hard
he's got to be strong but he can still
be delicate if it needs to be because
he's so strong that he knows that he can
snap out of that really really fast
and that's it I still think cheating is
disgusting of course agreed if a woman
tweeted on you would you stay [__] no no
it's a complete double standard it's not
fair at all I agree it's a complete
double standard it's not fair at all but
you know what I know well if a woman
truly loves a man she doesn't see other
men and then she can't even see them
I agree with that because there's been
times when I really like someone and it
doesn't matter how attractive another
person is see you straight to him that's
just I'm not interested yeah but a man
that creates an atmosphere of of being a
real man creates real genuine desire and
it takes genuine desire to make other
men invisible when other men are
invisible that's when you're doing it
right
when I have a Facebook account full of
wives slotting in my DMs I know all
those dudes aren't doing it right as
many
as many I was just banned
band talk and
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible